[Music]
wow
that's claws at the beginning thanks
hunter so that person who just wooed i
just want to shout out that's a hundred
glands he's also at cal poly
we're both faculty and he helped me with
this project is involved in the
excuse me the coding and everything we
decided not to switch off talking in a
short session but
if you have questions etc you can ask
him as well so right there making noises
okay so in this talk i kind of just want
to tell you about what i've done with r
in the really really intro level classes
um
so the way i'm going to structure this
basically there's a lot of window
dressing i want to give you some
background on what courses we have at
cal poly the advantages and challenges
of using r in some of these classes
which i'm sure many of you are familiar
with
um and then like what my lab assignments
look like what are the students being
asked to do
and then the reason for the hamburger
apart from it being mid-afternoon
and lunch has worn off is that the meat
of this talk is these pre-lab exercises
that hunter and i have built in shiny
that have kind of helped us
introduce our to beginners
and then i don't know i've got some okay
some student outcome
uh information i've surveyed the
students so hopefully you think lettuce
is also important to hamburgers
um and oh i forgot that i have a clicker
i'm not used to this fanciness
uh yeah so and then some take home
messages advice if any of you are
teaching such classes
so at cal poly the courses using r we do
have a dedicated
r class so that one you would hope
involves r in some way
but we also have a lot of upper level
classes and those will involve some
coding in order to get the concepts
across et cetera
most of the professors seem to favor r
although it's up to our
discrepan decision there but then we
also have these service level classes
what we call the introductory classes
for non-majors and these are the classes
where
there's no stat or cs background there's
no prerequisites of any kind
and so everyone agrees that these
students should see software in some way
but typically people are using applets
there's some debate
over whether we should use r or use
something an applet or jump or minitab
some of these easier kind of point and
click approaches um
that's debatable there's no opposition
to using r
as kind of the tool but what is really
kind of unpopular
is that students in these classes should
code because these are not stat or cs
majors these are for my class they're
bio majors
viticulture food science animal science
things like that
so this is the class i want to talk
about is the service level class that i
teach
and i do think there's a lot of
advantages to introducing coding in this
class
you may or may not agree with me
pedagogically i think that
thinking through things with code forces
them to not just memorize steps
one of the steps of a hypothesis test or
a t-test or
same thing linear regression etc they
have to kind of plan ahead plan their
output
and not memorize formulas conceptually i
think
we live in an age where data is all
digital and so thinking of data as a
digital object and how do people
interact with it
um it's a good way to kind of interface
with how this is being done in the real
world
and to think of data as information and
not a list of numbers that's handed to
you on an exam
and then practically speaking of course
not all of them are going to be
data scientists or creators but um they
do
need to understand how it's done in the
real world um
i don't know why we are still using
these t tables here
um normal z tables nobody uses that in
the real world we're all just going to
use p norm q norm or
our language of choice if this were not
an r conference
it makes no sense to be using things in
class that are never ever ever going to
be encountered in the real world
so this is my opinion anyway that i
think these students should
benefit from seeing code it's not always
easy though
um these are i keep forgetting you know
we don't have these at cal poly it's a
state school
so some of the challenges that i've
encountered with these
new students uh logistically uh i i went
in the first time i used r in this class
i was gung-ho i had put so much thought
into how to make
this gentle you know and introduce them
to coding and what i
instead dealt with for the whole class
is where's my downloads folder
um these kids are 17 to 23
i thought they'd grown up with computers
and it was natural but i've learned
there's kind of a sweet spot in between
the people that are frightened of
computers and the people that are
frightened of
downloads folders so that was a
challenge
there's ways around it and i don't want
to dwell on this too much this is very
important to the class but it's not
really my contribution so
there's many better people than i to
speak of this but i just want to mention
using cloud servers has really helped in
this class rstudio cloud is awesome
amazon web services you can set up your
own home cloud which is what we've done
at cal poly
and then using notebooks you know to
feed them code
that helps or to to call your own
scripts etc github classroom is really
cool i've just gotten started with that
that's a nice way to
just package everything off to these
students and then they use this package
it's kind of idiot-proof as they say so
these things can help
i would just point you to those if
you're interested in using
r for people that are frightened of
downloads folders
but anyway the other challenges that i
run into besides those logistics are
pedagogical i want to involve coding in
my teaching but i'm not teaching coding
i'm teaching statistics and i'm teaching
concepts of statistics and so how do i
do that without ending up just teaching
coding
and what i get in feedback a lot is we
spent all this time learning r and it
wasn't on the exam
i did put our output that they have to
read on the exam but they don't have to
write code there's no coding questions
and so forth
so this is a big question of kind of how
to synthesize those ideas
and then these students are mostly
students who are forced to take stat
don't want to take stat they don't think
they like math
and so it just adds one more thing for
them to be scared about in this
in this intro class so i did a survey
i did some extensive surveys of my class
this fall that ended
just in december and this is what the
students had to say i had the question i
feel nervous about my ability to
complete the lab assignment
and over the first three lab assignments
here they're pretty nervous right more
than half of them are saying that they
strongly agree or agree
that they're nervous about it and it
wasn't really getting better actually
across the assignments so this is
something they find daunting
and i will readily admit that that it's
a challenge for them
so let me tell you what these
assignments are that are so terrifying
that i'm using in my class
um when i first started out okay so
here's an example of a data set that i
use i'm sure many of you have seen it
it's the wine data set
we've got a whole bunch of chemical
measures of wine
and then we've got this measure at the
bottom quality that's going to say if
it's a good or a bad wine as rated by
experts
so the idea is what um different
chemical properties does the wine have
to be a good wine
and so in my first version of these labs
and these are just snippets from the
labs they're obviously much
longer and formatted differently but i
just give them
this t-test code and i ask them
questions about it and their job is to
look at that output
and interpret it correctly so it's not
really
coding right it's reading output but
it's not coding
and then the next version was kind of
reproduce my process so first i would
do the same thing ask them something
give them that code and then i'd say
well here what i asked them about was ph
level does the ph level of the wine
matter to the quality
and then i said now suppose i've made
some claim about density can you back
that claim up
and all they're going to do is copy
paste and write density where ph
is or ideally that's what they're going
to do you'd be surprised the number of
different things
they would do such as writing
t.test.density
weird stuff like that because they're so
new to this
version three um is where i really think
my students are being statisticians this
is where
i have not given them almost anything i
have said choose three chemical
attributes of the wine
make me some plots do some t-tests this
is what their lab assignment literally
looked like
on this and this is the third lab
assignment so this is week four i don't
do one the first week
of a ten week course so this is cool
right i think it's really cool that
non-majors can handle this and they
really can but how do i get them there
is the question
without having given them anything right
here to work with
so what we came up with this kind of
intermediate transition
tool is these pre-lab exercises in
shiny and so where this idea came from
was
at icots the conference on teaching
statistics in japan last summer um
hunter and i
went to two talks i think there's a rule
that you have to quote hadley if you're
going to talk at this conference that's
what i heard
but really there are these two talks
back to back that really influenced us
the main one was emilia mcnamara
saying we need a bridge between there's
learning statistics those are applets
and there's doing statistics that's
being a true programmer a coder and and
there's
there's not really a bridge in between
these things right now and this kind of
matched a vision that i've had for a
long time floating in my brain
and then hadley backing up that not all
statisticians need to be
coders but if you're not interacting
with code are you really doing
statistics i
i think the challenges and the
advantages pedagogically they all pale
in comparison to the fact that
if we're offering to teach statistics
and we don't teach them to think about
it as
a digital process we are not teaching
them statistics that's my opinion
i'm sure many will disagree but i would
love to argue with you
so that's the idea so that's where this
came from so hunter and i we went
upstairs at this conference and we sat
down amongst all the japanese business
people having lunch
and we coded for a couple hours and then
spent the whole summer continuing to
develop these things so the idea is the
principles behind these tools
we figured they should kind of have
immediate results right what's nice
about applets is the students go
very quickly to seeing output that is
exciting and interpretable
so we wanted to maintain that to kind of
immediately see
the uh process but then we wanted to
require them to be generating the
queries to not be selecting from a drop
down menu or
clicking a checkbox or so forth as a
real coder would
and we also want to make really clear
what's kind of built into r versus what
they're choosing because this is not
an r specific i'm not trying to teach
them r so i want them to be able to
interact then with another language
and understand we have to think about
what variables we're using even if the
function to make a box plot or whatever
has a different name
and then i really wanted to link the
concepts and questions from lecture
the big ideas to what was happening with
the code
so i want to do a demo here
and i've got a backup plan but i think
these are working fine on shinyapps.io
so i'll have these links at the end i've
got three of these hosted on
shinyapps.io if you want to demo them
for the class we hosted them separately
because shiny apps would get pummeled
and i would not be able to handle it on
my free account
but these ones are here if you guys want
to try them so the idea here is this was
their first lab exercise
it's built on learn r so someone asked a
question earlier
a really nice package for this kind of
thing and
the key here is that what we're going to
do
is we have the titanic data set for all
of these exercises
and they have to choose the variables so
let's say we want to look at gender
and then we want to see who survived
there we go and so what this does and
kind of the key point
is it fills in that code line there he
said okay i can zoom in
a little bit there so that line of code
they're seeing the blue is the thing
that is you know a name that was chosen
but i chose it they didn't just input it
just now
and the red is the stuff that they just
selected and the rest of it is just the
syntax of this particular coding
language
and so then we see okay they used facet
grid and and that's
you can kind of get an idea what's going
on but not so great so we can go down to
stack bar charts
things like that make different choices
they can see the output immediately and
decide which of those plots answers
their question better which one is going
to show you
that men tended to die and women tended
to survive on the titanic
and so additionally we have this
idea of tying it to the concepts in
class so here's the exercise for t-tests
where we can say
all right i'd like to make claims about
the age on titanic
the age of the passengers and under the
null let's say 30
and let's say we're interested in
testing whether the average age was less
than 30 for some reason
and so we can see this in words that
they've been seeing in class the
hypothesis is that the true mean is
equal to 30 versus less than 30.
we can see this in code again with the
blue and red and then we can see the
output that they have to interpret
and learn r is nice it's got a good
interface for including some questions
we can say oh look what sample mean did
i observe well that was 29.5
47 there we go and it'll tell them right
away they got it right so they're able
to
kind of check and make sure that they've
gotten the output that was expected
and then the last one i want to show you
just to tie all these you know
principles together is
the normal random variables in general
so we could say something like
let's say we have a normal random
variable with the mean of 67
and a standard deviation of 3 and i'm
interested in the area below 60. so
again i'm tying this to the way they've
seen it in class which is sort of this
notation of
you know normally distributed and what's
the probability and then we can see the
code
the result and then i made these little
illustrations just so they can see
what's going on
what the picture looks like there so all
these things that they see typically in
lecture all in one place and kind of
being
dynamically generated thanks to the
magic of shiny and
and the coding that hunter and i have
done i suppose
so those are the exercises um
there we go and so let me tell you what
happened when i finally used these so i
started these out on my summer class
with only 18 students
and used them with 108 students this
fall
the first thing is students definitely
recognize that r is applicable
uh this question is says the in-class
lab activity helped me understand
how statistical analyses are conducted
in the real world they overwhelmingly
agree or at least feel neutrally about
that no one is arguing with that
they recognize the value to themselves
um this one says
the in-class activities helped me
understand the concepts from the week's
material
and you can see they kind of over time
started to see more how this was helping
them i don't know if that was a
progression as they got more comfortable
or if maybe that third lab
which had to do with the t-tests was
particularly helpful
one way or the other i like that was
positive and also that it improved over
these three labs that i surveyed heavily
on
i really like this one i asked i feel
proud of the work i produced on the
assignment the assignment being the
actual data analysis not these exercises
and they feel very proud of it almost
none of them feel
unproud of it um and most of them were
kind of excited and it was fun doing
these exercises to watch them hit knit
on their file and go
oh my gosh it worked this is cool you
know and explore this data
that was very rewarding for me anyway
i surveyed them pretty heavily on the
skills they gained
this one they were asked to agree or
disagree or whatever with i feel
confident in my ability to read and
interpret a bar plot
and that one it looks like the lab
helped so i surveyed them before
anything after the exercise and then
after the assignment itself the full
analysis and there seems to be some
improvement
happening i was hoping to find some
improvement over concepts and i didn't
actually really find that
mostly anything that was about
identifying aspects of data or
describing aspects of data
they did not self-report improving
although anecdotally i do actually feel
that they did
and then small improvements for anything
to do with creating or analyzing plots
and a little bit to do with calculating
things
so some feedback i'm hanging myself out
to dry here reading one of my least
favorite sentences
that i've ever received but in summer
one of my students
described these as a complete
unorganized catastrophic mess
i was having a lot of trouble figuring
out how to host them shiny apps
couldn't handle all my students and i
had to relearn unix to host them
elsewhere so there was some technical
difficulties
i tried it on that class because there
was only 18 of them so i could help them
out
but for the 108 in this past fall it
went very smoothly and
here's um three of the comments people
are saying that they thought these labs
were helpful
there were some slightly negative
comments but nothing like this one they
were more i don't understand why we did
it
instead of i hated it so so that was
encouraging
and lastly i didn't survey heavily my
previous classes i didn't know i was
going to be doing
kind of experimenting like this um but
in winter 2018 i also had three sections
about the same time
same number of students homework was
pretty much identical i didn't tweak it
too much
between winter and fall and the lab
material was the same the same data sets
and questions but it was split
for the fall into this pre-lab and lab
format
and so i asked them two questions
halfway through the quarter i asked them
how much the homework assignments helped
and how much the lab assignments helped
and what we found was not a huge change
in the homework
um from winter to fall which you'd
expect it's the same homework
but the lab assignments if you see here
i don't know why i keep forgetting this
exists
these lab assignments here um in the
winter like three-fourths of my class
hated them
or didn't think they were useful and in
the fall most of the class did think
they were useful or at least felt
neutral so i think that is maybe
attributable to these exercises
so just some take-home messages what
worked well well i like that the
students could analyze data from scratch
themselves i anecdotally i really think
the students ended up better off in the
winter class or the fall class
i like seeing them get excited about
results what didn't work
well first of all these exercises we
banged them out
we are not developers we're trying to be
we're getting there but we're not um
i'm gonna hang myself out to dry again
this is kind of what it looks like when
i have to input to output both the
strings of code and also
evaluate that code in particular
i'm just going to really hang myself out
to dry a lot of people i know will get
mad at me for that
eval parse i know it's a crime but i
don't know what else to do and i wanted
to do something and something is better
than nothing so there we are sorry dave
robinson
um and so
apart from that and this is kind of why
i'm sharing it with you one reason is
in the hopes that there's people out
there who might want to help me make
this more of a
usable shareable manageable tool
i think this idea of thinking through
code students tended to
type their variable names for the new
data into the exercise which of course
wouldn't run but then they would copy
paste which isn't quite what i was
hoping but maybe it's okay
and motivating the students they really
were disturbed by the fact that they
were spending class time on something
that wasn't on the exam
so my advice for you the growing pains
are worth it there is a headache but
it's worth it um
i think if you have an idea for a
teaching tool build it it's not perfect
mine is ugly but it's cool and it helped
um and that these kids can handle r they
really can like they're
they grew up with computers um they can
do more than they think they can they
can think about data
uh they can do it and so can the people
teaching them so i hope that
more interest classes will really engage
with coding instead of just applets in
the future that's my goal
all right so the github repository there
has all the material for these exercises
if you want to use or
better yet edit them those three demos
the links are here
um and then contact info for me or
hunter and
that's all i got
we have time for one question um
uh hi um this is a great talk thank you
very much um
so a lot of times when i hear these
discussions about
um sort of computing and statistics
pedagogy they're like kind of along
two veins one is i think kind of what
you're doing here which is
using r and shiny and these kinds of
tools to improve the teaching
of classical topics and the other one is
to kind of
replace like the sort of teaching of
classical topics with more
computationally
based stuff like permutation testing
bootstrap stuff like that right up front
instead of
normal derivations of t-tests things
like that i was wondering if that sort
of like second
component of it is as something like you
and your colleagues have like
discussed as like you're you know
incorporating more of this stuff into
the
these earlier classes yeah totally so i
think the question is about like
using computing just to reinforce things
like t-tests versus to
introduce things like permutation tests
that get the spirit of hypothesis
testing without the math maybe necessary
um yeah that's a big discussion i think
beth chance teaches a class like fully
on simulation permutation tests and none
of the other stuff
for me i kind of believe in teaching the
classical concepts because they are
going to
see that even if they never do stat
they're going to read papers in their
fields and it's probably going to have a
t-score they should know what that is
and so mostly i've been using it to
reinforce those concepts but also
i do feel really strongly about don't do
something in a class that is never ever
going to happen in a real world
so as maybe those things go away then it
would make more sense to
emphasize the other stuff yeah